[Music]
sex tape you're in this movie with
Cameron Diaz who is naked in the movie
some of the movie yeah some of the movie
yeah looking very good good she's a
beautiful woman she has a beautiful body
she should be naked all the time and we
were at the premiere the other night and
I thought oh rowdy crowd everyone's
gonna be whooping a lot and I thought
for sure when Cameron Diaz came out for
the first time not wearing much clothing
people would be whooping you know I kept
calling whatever so I started to go what
and like no one else did and my sister
like hit me like we're doing and I
realize like so I look like just the
biggest pervert like I'm cheering for
Cameron Diaz's right naked self yeah but
if you go I encourage you to whoop
because it's worth looping for yes the
beautiful naked female body yes that is
what it is yeah I think it's better when
women whoop at a naked woman it comes it
comes across differently than if I start
going whoop whoop you know it's
wonderful
yeah no no no it just is it's a sad show
you